you see this also with pornography in
school libraries that's become a huge
thing
yeah do you mean pornography pornography
in school libraries has become a giant
thing in the U.S because what do you
mean parents keep finding pornography in
their kids school library what do you
mean by pornography I mean you it would
shock you
the thing that I see that makes me want
to get the flamethrower out frankly is
that's a metaphor by the way [__]
literal I want to get the Flames when I
see a drag queen in a g string twerking
in front of kids I want to get the
flamethrower yeah I get that because you
know this this conversation started with
drag queens Story Hour at your local
library and you know it's interesting
because I think that a lot of parents at
the time were like oh it's the big deal
it's like a clown reading to your kids
like who cares
um and then it spiraled into this
g-string thing where when's the last
time you saw them read a book to kids
like this drag queen Story Hour has
turned into drag queen's working hour
and we're supposed to just accept it and
there's so many examples like that where
the slippery slope is just does not
allow for any kind of Middle Ground I
think that you know in the past I would
have said like oh I'll call people
whatever pronoun they they ask me but
then it went to they and that's already
iffy and then they went to like sure and
I don't even know what that is and now
like there are literally just so many
others I you can't keep playing this
game it's like you have to say no early
now and it's
it sucks because like I don't think I
cared when drag queen Story Hour first
hit I think I thought you know who cares
if you want if parents want to take
their kids to this whatever but now when
I see that you know the g-string
twerking I'm like no make that illegal
right now and where is that coming from
because I don't understand I I don't I
don't yeah I'm getting old I don't
understand
why why do children need to be
exposed to obviously sexualized Behavior
I don't care if it's a drag queen I I
don't care if it's a stripper I don't
care if it's the mental Drive creature
it's never going to be a stripper that's
the whole thing they get it they get you
or they get other people to say that
this is okay through using LGBT you know
um Community right because if you go
Stormy Daniels to tell me exactly nobody
would be like oh yeah this is important
right nobody thinks it's okay for a
woman to you know dance around in six
inch heels and a g-string for kids but a
man dressed as a woman becomes okay you
see this also with pornography in school
libraries that's become a huge thing
yeah what do you mean pornography
pornography in school libraries has
become a giant thing in the U.S because
what do you mean parents keep finding
pornography in their kids school library
what do you mean by pornography I mean
you it would shock you not like not like
you know I mean you haven't seen this
phone
just a joke it's just
um it's books that literally talk about
show pictures of sex acts but yeah look
when I was a kid my parents when I was a
teenager gave me a book which was
educational about sex did it have
somebody on their knees and giving oral
sex uh no no no right so no
um and did it have like sexting in it
where two boys sexed each other dirty
pictures or ask for really graphic
things to be sent to them it didn't and
you would be again you would be shocked
and it's happening at elementary schools
so in the US again that's till fifth
grade that's 11 12 years old is where
elementary school ends in Florida
Governor DeSantis has made you know made
them go through all the libraries and
for this is called a book banner and
remove a certain uh these books that
they know that they exist right so he
sent out so he had a press conference
where he was talking about what books
they were getting rid of and he started
reading from these books and news
channels had to pull away from his press
conference because they can't show that
on TV they can't have that language on
so you can't show that to 10 year olds
but you can show that to 10 year olds
and The Quirk here is it's always always
a gay story
because you you know you can't show
straight sex at that age to kids but
somehow it becomes okay when it's a gay
story and this is how they are able to
protect themselves from a lot of
criticism because you know we're just
showing LGBT youth um you know stories
about them and this if you have a
problem with this you're a bigot Carol
you're not making this up are you swear
I'll I'll send you I will you can you
know I don't know if you're going to be
able to post the pictures but you will
be look up pornography elementary
schools Florida
Google history but Anton's our producer
mate we're going to do that on your
phone you have a look mate all right
yeah I hear you but we use the word they
and I think this is really important to
specify who are they there's a lot of
these
um I know I know that they it seems like
um I'm just I'm calling out some group
that doesn't some shadowy group that
doesn't exist but there's it comes from
a lot of different places
um so one of the examples again with one
of these pornographic books
um they are a 11 year old boy I think
around that age got up at a school board
meeting started reading from this book
again they're all shocked that please
stop speaking that's really disgusting
and they're like he's like I got this in
my Elementary School library he got it
from the librarian the librarian offered
him this book and then said if you like
it I have others like it
hi my name is Knox a jack uh I'm 11
years old and I go to Windham Middle
School I'm a sixth grader I was in the
library and
this book was on a stand I'd like to
read you a page
my back over my hips as I ask if we
should take off take our clothes off and
he's saying yes before I finish my
sentence he's pulling off my t-shirt
laughing when I can't undo his shirt
buttons he's undoing my belt I'm
reaching into his bedside drawer for a
condom we're kissing again we're rolling
over obviously you can see where this is
going I don't know if it's because we're
feeling especially emotional or just
tired or these past couple of weeks have
been too much but this reminds me so
much of the first time we had sex we
were both [__] terrified and the
whole thing was kind of terrible because
we didn't know what we were doing but it
was good too so good because we were a
mess of emotions and we were scared and
excited and everything felt new so this
sort of thing this sort of feels like
that Nick touches me like he's scared at
any minute
now this book was at my middle school
and it was on a stand when I rented it
out to show my dad it uh the librarian
asked if I wanted more and if I wanted a
graphic novel version
this is again happening where it's at
every level we have a chapter on
libraries and book publishing where
again
super woke completely ideologically
captured and pushing a very specific
agenda
this and now look I'm looking at it
through a UK teacher's lens and I go
back to my training this breaks every
single safeguarding guideline that I
have ever heard that I've ever heard
because if someone told me that a boy in
my class or a girl doesn't matter was
getting
content or books which have sexual
connotations and pornographic that to me
is grooming and I would have to report
it well and if I didn't report it I
would get in problem I would get in
trouble quite rightly so it's absolutely
grooming and it's grooming them to not
have a perspective on what safety is not
being able to say this doesn't feel
right to me because you're supposed to
be okay with all of it you must see
these books because the fact that you
haven't you haven't seen these I I don't
know if again I would love to hear if
this is happening in UK schools once you
see like the book titles because they're
really common here it's not like it's
not like two schools founded it's like
dozens and dozens of schools found it
just in Florida in other states and it's
it's everywhere
thank you